[Mirana] Are you sure
you should be drinking?
-You don't look well.
-Hence the drinking.
Uh, get you ladies something?
It's on the house.
Just directions.
We're looking for the Black Market.
What business do respectable ladies
have in a place like that?
Private business.
I meant no offense.
It's on King's Way, uptown,
right off the main square.
You can't miss it.
Allow me to escort you.
It's not safe in the city after dark.
[vomits]
-Ugh!
-[retches]
You know how to impress a lady.
[Davion heaving]
[vomits]
[clanking]
Was that in your stomach? How?
[whimpers]
I don't know.
The fuck! Did you just heave up this ring?
This belonged to a friend of mine.
A brother.
He was found on the road, torn to pieces,
with five more of my brothers.
-You did this!
-No.
They found dragon armor around the bodies.
-"Davion the Dragon Knight."
-It's not possible!
-[thwacks]
-[grunts]
Savage! Fucking cannibal!
[grunts]
-[slams]
-[groans]
[whimpers]
Tomorrow. Midday.
My brothers and me, we're coming for you.
You're a dead man.
You hear me? A dead man!
-[Davion groaning]
-[thuds]